[Alkış]
[Müzik]
Burada konuşma yapmak için davet
geldiğinde ilk sorduğum şey bu seneki
etkinliğin konsepti ne olacak soruydu
kesişimler yanıtını aldıktan sonra
açıkçası çok fazla başka bir Soru
sormaya gerek kalmamıştı direkt
programın uygunluğuna bakıp kabul ettim
çünkü benim hayatımın ve kariyerimin
geneline şöyle tepeden kuş bakışı bir
bakışla bakma şansımız olsa en kritik
dönemeçlerde
insanlarım kesişimler var o kesişimler
bana yeni kapılar açtı O kapılar hiç
beklenmedik Hiç hesapta olmayan
koridorlar açıldı O koridorlardan
yolculuk uzayıp
devam böyle anlattığım zaman Tab şim
diyebilirsiniz ki bugü kadarki yaın
sahip olduklar kariyerin ya da bugüne
kadar biriktirdik acaba tamamen
teskir tesadüf denen ve çoğunlukla
küçümseyerek bahsettiğimiz şeylerin
Aslında çok kıymetli olduğunu bana pek
çok farklı olayda
gösterdi tesadüf zaten kelime anlamı
olarak bir şeyle ya da biriyle zamanın
herhangi bir anında rast gelmeniz
yollarınızın kesişmesi anlamına geliyor
ama aslında bu kadar basit değil bir
referans noktası olması Ya da bir
şekilde bir arayış içerisinde olmanız o
yaşadığınız tesadüfleri anlamlı hale
getiriyor Hani dersiniz ya bazen tam da
işte böyle bir iş arıyordum Tam da o
kitabı okuyordum ben de ya da aklımda
gerçekten tam olarak böyle biriyle
birlikte olmak vardı gibi soruları gün
içerisinde farklı versiyonlarıyla
birbirimize söylüyoruz veya kuruyoruz
işte İçimizden geçirdiğimiz Aklımızdan
geçenler düşüncelerimiz ve daha sonra
gerçeğe dönüştükten sonra hayatımıza
dokunarak bir şekilde hayatımıza yepyeni
kapılar açan o tesadüfler ya da o
kesişimler gerçekten çok derin eş
zamanlılık içeriyor hayat bana genel
itibariyle bunu öğretti ben kendi
hayatımdan tane kritik kesiyi ya da 3
tane kritik olayı anlattığımda neden
hayatın bana bunu öğrettiğini bir
şekilde sizinle paylaşmış olacağım
esasında ben uçak mühendisiyim
profesyonel Mesleğim bu ve profesyonel
Mesleğimi nasıl seçtim biliyor musunuz
tesadüfen ve
kesişimler Çünkü hepimiz şu anda Bu
salonda bulunan herkes aynı eğitim
sisteminin defoları
Aslında sistem bizi sevdiğimiz ya da
hayalini kurduğumuz yeteneklerimizle
örtüşen mesleğe yönlendirecek bir e
sistem değil Maalesef
bu sistem bizi daha çok yarış atına
dönüştüren Eee ve bu yarış atına
dönüştürmekle beraber bir yarışın
içerisindeyken yolumuzu bulmamızı
sağlayan bir sistem kendi yolumuzu ne
kadar Bulabilirsek O biraz bize bağlı
kalıyor Dolayısıyla ben de Tıpkı bu
eğitim sisteminin bir Eee Ferdi olduğum
için benzeri bir yolculuktan geçtim
biliyorsunuz Bu yarış yarış atı dediğim
sistemin içinde olduğumuz yarış Aslında
ana sınıfında başlıyor ana sınıfında ilk
olarak p pek deliği kim takacak da
başlıyor yarış ilkokula geçtiğimizde İlk
Okuma yazmayı kim sökecek de devam
ediyor sonrasında iyi bir Anadolu
Lisesine fen lisesine girebilme yarışı
la devam ediyor ve en sonunda da iyi bir
üniversitenin iyi bir bölümüne kendimizi
atamızla ilgili bir yarışın
içerisindeyiz sonra 23 22'li 23'lü
yaşlarda elinde bir diplomayla ne
yapacağını bilmeden bugüne kadar ne
yapacağını düşünmemiş ama bir
profesyonel mesleğe sahip olmasını
sağlayacak bir diplomaya sahip olan
sudan çıkmış balığa dönmüş nitelikli
gençler enflasyonunun bir parçası haline
geliyoruz hepimiz bu yollardan geçtik
Ben de benzeri bir yoldan geçtiğim için
hayatım bir anlamda tesadüflere Bu
anlamda bağlıydı ve o tesadüfler
dediğimiz şeyin esasında kapıları nasıl
açtığı ilgili bir mesele yani biz
sevdiğimiz iş yapalım diye sosyal bir
baskı görüyoruz ailemizden çevremizden
ya da yeteneklerimizin örtüştüğü bir
meslekle haşır neşir olalım istiyoruz
ama biz üniversiteden mezun olup
elimizde bir diplomaya sahip oluncaya
kadar hangi mesleği sevdiğimizi
yeteneklerimizle hangi mesleğin örtüşen
düşünmeye bile Fırsat bulamıyoruz
Neticede elimizde bir diplomayla artık
bir iş arayışı içerisine giriyoruz Ben
de 2008 yılında İzmir'de üniversiteye
hazırlanırken tam olarak benzeri bir
durumdaydım çok yakın arkadaşlarım gibi
ben de Türkiye'nin herhangi bir
yerindeki tıp fakültesine doğru aslında
yönlendirilmiş bir şekilde sistem beni
oraya yönlendirmiş bildiğim tek bir şey
vardı doktor olmak istemiyordum açıkçası
ama ne olmak istediğimi bilmiyordum bunu
düşünmeye fırsatım olmamıştı ve
yeteneklerimin neyle örtüştüğünü Elbette
bilmiyordum pek çok kişi gibi Ve
hayatımı gerçekten rayından çıkaran ve
makasın tamamen başka bir noktasına
geçmemi sağlayan o kesişme yaşandı o gün
tercih döneminin bitmesine birkaç gün
kala İzmir'de dershanedeki rehber
öğretmenimin odasında
on Boeing çal bir uçak mühendisi
arkadaşıyla karşılaşt o güne kadar uçak
mühendisli ilgili bir bölüm olduğunun B
farkında değildim onunla karşılaştıktan
sonra o bana uçak mühendisliğinin ne
olduğunu ne iş yaptığını Türkiye'de ve
dünyada havacılığın potansiyel olarak
nerelere gideceğinden filan bahsetti
Aklıma da yatmıştı olabilir dedim ve
yaklaşık bir ay sonra İstanbul
kay gi sağlıyor E tabii üniversiteye ya
da profesyonel Mesleğinizi
belirleyeceğiniz o işe ya da o sektöre
yönelirken böylesine bilinçli bir karar
verdiyseniz bir süre sonra elbette
kafanızda çeşitli anksiyeteler ve soru
işaretleri oluşmaya başlıyor ben bu
okulu nasıl bitireceğim bitirdikten
sonra ne yapacağım diye biraz geç de
olsa bir şekilde oturdum Uçak
mühendisleri Türkiye'de dünyada ne iş
yapar Ben bitirince ne yapabilirim diye
şöyle bir araştırmaya başladım ve
Havacılık ilgilenenler varsa bilirler
havacılıkta chek listler çok önemlidir
kendime ü maddeden oluşan bir çeklist
oluşturdum sektörlere baktım İnsanlar en
çok nerede çalışıyor diye savunma
sanayiyi belirledim işte Türkiye'deki
hava yolu şirketleri ve aynı zamanda
otomotiv sektöründe çok fazla uçak
mühendisi olduğunu gördüm ve dedim ki
benim bir şekilde mezun oluncaya kadar
bunları gerek yarı zamanlı çalışarak
gerek buralarda stajlar yaparak gerek
gönüllü ücretsiz çalışmalarla benim bu
sektörleri bir şekilde
deneyimlemiş bana ait olduğunu bir
şekilde keşfedeyim yeteneklerim
örtüşüyor mu seveceğim bir meslek mi ne
yapacağım En azından buna karar
verebilmek için İhtiyacım olan şeyim Bu
olduğuna karar verdim bir gün fakültede
duvarda panoda dev bir ilan
gördüm Türkiye'nin en önemli savunma
sanayi şirketlerinden bir tanesinin staj
ilany ve bu sıradan bir staj değildi
yalnız Eğer buna kabul edilirseniz mezun
oluncaya kadar her yaz 3 ay boyunca
gidip orada stajını
gerçekleştiriyorsunuz bir miktar size
küçük bir para veriyorlar Eee ve siz
sektörü şirketi ve işleyişi
öğreniyorsunuz günün sonunda karşılıklı
bir memnuniyet durumu olursa mezun
olduktan sonra sizi işe alıyorlar işte
benim çek liseki savunma sanayi kalemi
için oldukça uygun bir şeydi çok büyük
bir heyecanla gittim hemen başvuru
yapmak için çünkü buna kesinlikle kabul
edilmeliydi Çünkü bunu görmeliydim ama
not ortalamamın bu staja başvurmak için
yeterli olmadığını söylediler yıkıldım
tabii yani Neticede büyük bir Yükseliş
ve hemen arkasından not ortalamamın buna
yetmediğini öğrendiğim bir tablo aradan
aylar geçti yaklaşık bir ik ay kadar bir
gün fakültenin kapısında
arkadaşlarımızla Oturur sohbet ederken
fakültenin kapısına bir araç
yaklaştı ve aracın içerisinden çok iyi
giyimli bir kadın ve bir adam indi son
derece kibar ve iyi bir görünümleri
vardı fakültenin kapısına doğru geldiler
karşılıklı bakıştık gülüştük ve Günaydın
dedikten sonra bana Kampüs fakültenin
içerisindeki toplantı salonunun yerini
sordular Ben de tarif ettim teşekkür
ettiler
Alak birde la arasında benim o birka
aşamadığım stın mülakatlarını ym
geldiklerini söylediler
şaşırdım y bunu söylemelerine B gerek
yoktu esasında O esnada Çünkü bu konumuz
değildi ve o sırada bir ampul yandı Tab
B arkalarından birka dakika sonra gittim
kapıyı çaldım hazırlıklarını
yapıyorlardı bilgisayar falan
kuruyorlardı birka dakikan var mı bir
şey söylemek istiyorum dedim Tab
dediler
buğ
ist seçimlerinin yapılırken not
ortalamasının tek Kriter olmaması
gerektiğini anlattım dilim döndüğünce
Neticede Üniversitede 1 sınıfta bir
öğrenciydim ve dedim ki mümkünse bugün
yapacağınız mülakatları tamamladıktan
sonra mevcut akış içerisinde bittikten
sonra benimle de bir mülakat yapmak
ister misiniz dedim ve telefon numaramı
bir kağıda yazıp önlerindeki masaya
bırakıp çıktım arayacaklarını
düşünüyordum açıkçası deli galiba falan
bile diyebilirler belki bilmiyorum ne
düşündüklerini bilmiyorum O esnada ve
saatler sonra telefonum çaldı öyle
[Müzik]
kü şirketin içerisindeki bütün
departmanlara tamamen rastlantısal bir
şekilde yerleştiriyorlar farklı
departmanlara sizi atıyorlar beni
kompozit alanına atmıştır Neticede o
esay kadar ben havacılıkta malzeme dersi
gibi bölüm derslerini filan görmemiştim
daha temel dersleri görmüştüm kompozit
denen şeyin ne olduğu hakkında gerçekten
ama gerçekten hiçbir fikrim yoktu ve
sonra baktım ki işin içine girdikten
sonra kompozit dediğimiz şey malzeme
kavramı ve malzeme biliminin ve
dolayısıyla havacılık end endüstrisinin
geleceği miş bayağı çok ciddi bir
şekilde havacılık endüstrisinin
geleceğini ilgilendiren bir yerde staj
yapmaya başlamıştım inanılmaz da ilgimi
çekti orada yaptığım staj çok verimli
oldu Sonra kalktım Ben okulu bitirdikten
sonra kompozitle ilgili yüksek lisansımı
tamamladım Şu an hala doktora eğitimime
devam ediyorum ve bugün faaliyet
göstermiş olduğum kendime ait şirketin
faaliyet alanlarından bir tanesi uçakta
havacılık endüstrisinde kullanılan
kompozit parçaların hem satıcı hem
tahiry le ilgili hizmetler veriyoruz
yani hayatımı gerçekten bambaşka bir
yola sevk eden bugün profesyonel olarak
para kazanmamı sağlayan kendime ait
şirketin faaliyet alanını belirleme yol
açmıştı O bahsettiğim koridor Varan i
oldu bir tanesi bo çalışan uçak
mühendisi ikincisi fakültenin kapısında
karşılaştığım staj insan kaynakları
görevi üniversitedeyken öğrenci
kulüpleriyle uluslararası yarışmalarla
yarışma ekipleriyle proje ekipleriyle
çok
ilgilendim birçoğuna girip çıktım
bazılarında hiçbir faaliyette bulunmadım
bazılar destek verdim bazılarına gönüllü
katıldım filan bazılarını da işin bir
ucundan tuttum ama benim için en önemli
Ve hayatımdaki en gurur verici
başarılardan bir tanesine dahil olduğum
model uydu takımıyla
kavuştum üniversitemizdeki model uydu
takımlarından bir tanesinin 7edi
üyesinden birisiydim ve Amerika Birleşik
Devletleri'nde organizatörleri arasında
NASA'nın filan da yer aldığı olağanüstü
büük korkunç büyük bir yarışmaya
katılmaya karar verdik E tabii elimizde
para yok imkan yok Maddi manevi hiçbir
şey yok ama çok ciddi bir motivasyon var
sadece ne olduğu nereden geldiğini
bilmediğimiz bir motivasyon çok büyük ve
zor şartlar altında şirketlere para
dilenip işte uçak bileti dilenip
Amerika'ya gidecek bir Eee netice
itibariyle bir bilete ihtiyacımız var 7
kişiyiz Eee orada işte o bir uydu
tasarlamanız istiyorlar sizden bir yıl
boyunca onu tasarlıyordu sıfırdan bir
sürü görev veriyorlar size orada
Amerika'ya gittiğinizde yarışma günü
geldiğinde üretmiş olduğunuz kendinizin
sıfırdan yapmış olduğunuz bu uydunun
çeşitli görevleri gerçekleştirmesini
istiyorlar sizden E tabii Hayal var Emek
var maddi imkansızlıklar var filan ve
bir şekilde Amerika'da 2012 yılında
Haziran ayında texas'ta düzenlenen bu
yarışmada mı Stanford gibi üniversiteler
filan var yani Öyle basit
üniversitelerden filan bahsetmiyoruz
rakiplerimiz arasında dünya birincisi
olduk hem de rekor bir puanla hem de
bugün o yarışma yıllardır 3040 yıldır
devam eden bugün hala devam eden bir
yarışma ve bu yarışmada bugün hala bizim
aldığımız 2012 yılında aldığımız puanı
alan birisi yok bir grup yok rekor bir
puanla üzerinden 102,5 puan alarak rekor
bir puanla dünya birincisi olduk korkunç
bir başarı Biz çıldırıyoruz Amerika'da e
geldiğimizde bizi o futbolculara
karşılama törenleri yapılır ya öyle
filan tören yapılacak zannediyoruz
hakikaten çıldırdık böyle bizi herhalde
de kucaklarda filan karşılayacaklar
olağanüstü sevinçliyiz filan uçaktan
indik hiç kimse yok bir teşekkür dahi
edilmedi bize ve ertesi sene çok daha
ilginci ertesi sene üniversitenin her
öğrenci projesinin ekibine vermiş olduğu
o standart bütçeyi dahı vermediler biz
başarımız cezalandırıldı Klasik Türkiye
ve biz ertesi sene yarışmaya katılamadı
netice itibariyle Şampiyon Takım ertesi
sene yarışmaya katılamadı filan çünkü
para bulamadık ama ben tabii ki ne
yaptım Her zamanki gibi yılmadım
televizyon televizyon gazete gazete
sesimizi duyurmaya çalıştım dedim ki biz
böyle bir şey yaptık bizim başımıza
böyle bir iş geldi bizim sesimizi
duyurmam gerekiyor Ne yapmamız lazım
filan birkaç yere katıldım iyi kötü
çıktık filan ama çok fayda etmedi
dediğim gibi ertesi sene yarışmaya
katılamadı zaten ama şöyle bir üncü
Varan 3 karşılaşma ve kesişim geliyor E
bir gün ben o sıralarda Bu arada
üniversitenin rektörlüğüne bağlı
kurumsal iletişim ofisinde de yarı
zamanlı olarak çalışıyorum öğrenci
Asistan öğrenci
olarak bir gün telefon çaldı ofiste
otururken birçok kişinin telefonu açma
ihtimali vardı ama telefonu ben
kaldırdım Çünkü birçok kişi için ortak
bir de telefon yeni açılan bir
televizyon kanalından aradığını
söylüyordu Karşıdaki kişi gençler ne
diyor isimli bir programımız var bu
yüzden ilginç konular arıyoruz sizin
üniversitenizin de kurumsal iletişim
ofisini aradık var mı elinizde ilginç
bir konu bizim programımız kapsamına
girebilecek dediler Ben de dedim ki uydu
yarışmasında dünya birincisi olan ekip
var ister misiniz İşinize yarar mı dedim
Tabii ki atladılar çok iyi konu Bilmem
ne filan sonra kendi cep telefonumu
verdim ona dedim ki şu şu kiş kişiler
üzerinden şu numaradan arayabilirsiniz
ama birkaç saat sonra arayayım belki
derstedir L sınav dönemi şu anda filan
dedim sonra bir ik saat sonra beni Cep
telefonumdan aynı kişi bu sefer aradı
işte bu sefer şeyi arıyor ama tabii
yarışmada birinci olan ekipten birisini
aradığını zannediyor filan
Neyse biz bir şekilde televizyon
programına gittik katıldık ve televizyon
programından çıktıktan sonra kanalın
yöneticileri de orada oturuyorlardı F
alanında sohbet ettik işte konuştuk
başarı ne güzel Başarı Teşekkürler filan
dediler ki Biz bu kanalı yeni açtık işte
böyle ilginç projeler fikirler varsa
hani siz de böyle parlak gençl siniz
varsa bir şey böyle bir şeyler yapalım
ya da Aklınızda bir şey varsa
değerlendirmek isteriz falan Ben de
dedim ki ya biz böyle böyle Başımıza bir
şey geldi ama biz bu alanda tek değiliz
Türkiye Türkiye'nin her yerinde
uluslararası arenada yarışmalara katılan
bir şeyler yapmak isteyen proje
geliştiren kendisine destek bulamayan
sesini duyuramayan insanlar var biz
bunların sesini duyuralım işte size bir
hem sosyal sorumluluk Hem aynı zamanda
bir program fikri hem de o insanlara bir
katkımız olur belki diye kabul ettiler
oky dediler güzel fikir ve bizim benim
konuk olarak gitmiş olduğum O program
yayından kaldırdı Ben onun yerine 52
bölüm televizyon programı yapmaya
başladım ha şöyle bir şey oldu Tabii o
programı sunan arkadaşı da enman yaptı
Allah'tan da en azından O da bu
kesişmeden zaten olmasını istediği şey
anman olmaktı ve ben de o konu hayatım
boyunca her şey söyledim yani benim
sayemde Sen de anman oldun diye çünkü
onun programı kaldırıldı ve onun yerine
ben 52 bölüm boyunca Türkiye'de
Bizimkine benzeyen bir şekilde
uluslararası projeler işte yarışmalara
filan katılan çeşitli başarıları olan
kaynak arayan destek arayan insanların
seslerini duyurmaya çalıştık bu Tabii
şunu getirdi Ben televizyon programı
nasıl yapılır ne yapılır bir programda
Medya sektöründe neler yapılır bunları
öğrendim Tabii bu işin içerisinde ve bu
bana Türkiye'nin en önemli ulusal
Gazetesi ve televizyonu olan bir medya
grubunda havacılıkla ilgili bir şeyler
yapma fırsatı açtı havacılık editörlüğü
havacılık programı havacılık yazarlığı
gibi ve orada edindikleri bana hem kendi
sektörüm ilgili hem de Medya alanında
yaptıklarımla ilgili bir yeni bir kapı
açmıştı E sonra tabii malum hepiniz
biliyorsunuz sosyal medya gelişti
dijital platformlar gelişti Ben de
geleneksel medyadan zaten bir alt olmaz
deyip kendi platformları üzerinden bir
şeyler yapmaya karar verdim çok çok uzun
bir zamandır kendisi dijital mecralar
üzerinden havacılık ilgili kendi
yayınlarımı yapıyorum belki aranızda
takip eden beni bir şekilde oralardan
tanıyan birisi varsa şu anda havacılıkla
ilgili o tırnak içinde influencer ya da
yayıncı dijital Medya yayıncısı
kimliğimi de işte bu ve buna benzer çok
çeşitli tesadüfler sonucunda elde
ettim ü tane kritik e olaydan bahsettim
size ve hayatımın tamamını aynı makastan
çıkaran farklı farklı makaslara sokmamız
sokmam sağlayan bir Eee tesadüfler
silsilesi ydi Bunlar Peki bu sadece bana
mı özgü bir şey iydi yani sizin
hayatınızda tesadüflere böylesine
derinlikli Eee eş zamanlılık vara ya da
derin eş zamanlılık vara yer olmadığını
mı zannediyorsunuz Bence hayır tesadüf
deyip geçtiğimiz Olur böyle şeyler
tesadüf Bunlar dediğimiz şeyler aslında
o kadar da göründükleri kadar masum
olmayabilir Sizin burada bu
bahsettiğimiz tesadüflere ne kadar açık
olduğunuz Sizin burada Eee o
bahsettiğimiz o anların o Gerçekten
sihirli anların sizin Bulunduğunuz
zamana ve zemine denk geldiğinde sizin
algılarının ne kadar açık olduğuyla
ilgili bu belki burnunuzun dibinde uzun
zamandır aradığınız fırsatın uzun
zamandır kovaladığın fırsatın olduğunu
görmemiş vazgeçmiş olabilirsiniz
algılarız kapalı olduğu için belki o
yüzden tesadüf dediğimiz şeyin
kurallarına göre Hareket edersek açmak
istediğimiz yol girmek istediğimiz
koridor ya da buna benzer şeylerin
Aslında gerçekten tam olarak Burnumuzun
dibinde olduğunu ve Bizim bazen bunu pas
geçip
söyleyebiliriz Robert tesadüfle ilgili
söylediği Bazı kurallar var ve bunların
tamamına katılıyorum bunlarla tamamlamak
istiyorum diyor ki Birlikte meydana
gelmeyi seven şeyler
vardır bunların bir araya gelmesiyle
oluşan ve birlikte meydana gelmeyi seven
şeyler vardır düşüncelerimiz aslında
birer eylemdir ve eylemler sonuçlar
üretir Biz eylemde kaldığımız sürece
tesadüflerin sayısı çoğ
ve karşılaştığımız engeller yaşadığımız
olumsuz durumlar başımıza gelen kötü
hadiseler Aslında bize yepyeni
fırsatların kapılarını açar
ve bazen yolumuzu bulabilmek için
tamamen kaybolmam gerekir ve işte
böylesine tamamen kaybolduğumuz anlarda
yapmamız gereken şeyse bizi İçinde
bulunduğumuz çıkmazdan kurtaracak o
gizli eli aramaya çalışmak ve Onu
bulmaya çalışmaktır çok uzun bir
zamandır üniversitelerde havalı bir
kariyer herkesin hakkı isimli söyleşiler
yapıyorum Ve o söyleşilerin standart bir
afişi var üzerindeki sadece
üniversitenin ismini değiştiriyoruz
saatini filan değiştiriyoruz o afişin
altında şöyle küçük bir ibare var Onu
ben afişi de ben tasarlamıştım altına
Ben yazdım tesadüfler doğru zamanda
doğru yerde olanlara rastlar
tesadüflerin ve kesişimler bol olsun
teşekkür ederim